when we started off we're probably like
doing the standard like fake it to make
it we're the specialist yeah we deliver
all these projects we work with all
these companies trying to like create
this kind of side that we're like the
absolute go-to company yeah and then
fast forward like 12 months we actually
became that company welcome to the
recruitment mentors podcast in this
week's episode i was joined by marius
from sr2 recruitment who ended up
building sr2's contract book from
scratch in a market he's never worked
him before so he broke down how at the
peak of his book it got to six and a
half weekly gp we broke down exactly how
he went about doing that and the
challenges along the way he's recently
come to london to set up the sr2's
london division and he also broke down
how he's gone about building a high
performance culture and how he believes
as a business they're able to hire
consistently experienced recruiters and
make them successful enjoy the episode
marius welcome to the podcast thank you
mate excited to be here no excited to
uncover this journey of yours thanks for
coming down i know you listened to the
podcast yeah so big fan you should you
should probably know the first question
but where you would like to
to start is probably the question that
you've really started to really think
about
as you're growing this london team
so obviously that question is i'd love
to hear your thoughts on like in your
opinion what characteristics and traits
do you really believe make up a a high
performing recruiter in in today's
market
yeah absolutely so i've thought about
this question quite a lot and i know
i've obviously listened to a lot of the
guests on the podcast and the standard
things like resilience hard-working like
that obviously goes without saying but i
think outside of that and what we've
probably found sr2 and within my team is
um i think it's someone who's got like
commercial acumen and someone who's like
quite commercially astute because i
think the successful recruits i've seen
treat their desk like a kind of business
and a lot of the work that we're doing
srt at the moment in the contract team
is around like selling like projects
selling solutions
quite trying to think quite big picture
and engage with quite senior
stakeholders and i think people have got
a big commercial acumen and maybe like a
bit of a business brain like ready to
excel do you think because this has come
up a lot actually since i've been having
a lot of these
learning development conversations
i do speak to owners and they're like
it'd be great if they did have a bit
more commercial awareness and typically
the story is
we have marius he's been on the phone
and there was an opportunity in that
conversation for him to go well you know
you told me you're having that challenge
yeah have you thought about
engaging us around that or whatever you
know that just having that like you said
that astuteness to go well let's further
the conversation or like have you
thought about speak to us about that do
you think you can develop that do you
think yeah it's a really good question
um i think you absolutely can i think um
for me and i think maybe like the team
we're quite into like kind of like
self-development so i think we're always
sharing like podcasts or like a good
book that we've read or obviously
listening to like your podcast and i
think trying to learn from people and
maybe look how people have done things
successfully kind of take inspiration
from that yeah so if you're at the start
of your journey and maybe you're kind of
not that aware you can almost kind of
look at who's doing well in the industry
and then think about kind of copying
what they're doing so yeah yeah so yeah
i guess you could probably influence it
by making sure that
the culture these people are in yeah
they're being encouraged to to learn
maybe think outside the box and yeah
okay yeah absolutely so there's quite a
lot we can go into here right but i
think obviously the key sort of themes
for everyone listening that i definitely
want to dig into today is really want to
sort of break down that journey that you
went on on building your contract but
from scratch i know a lot of people will
sort of uh want to learn from that then
i think obviously the other part then is
obviously you're now on this journey
you've obviously recently moved to
london
you know obviously building out a team
in london so then talking about
how sort of marist has gone about
building culture how he thinks about
culture and and the things that are just
really important as you grow that team
and i guess your journey with leadership
and how that's going
so i guess why don't we sort of dig
straight into
the contract piece and talk about that
so i guess just to give people context
just talk to us a bit about before you
got to sr2 recruitment yeah just really
high level what was the journey was
you're always doing just contract
permanent contract yeah what was the
markets you operated in and how and then
how long would you do recruitment for
before you joined srt and then we'll get
into it yeah absolutely um so i started
my career uh a company in swindon like
on actual like recruitment
apprenticeship oh wow really yeah
peanuts yeah it wasn't much at all so i
didn't really see that i've come up very
often it's like getting in sales and
learning sales
and it was a company called the people
network and i was there for about a year
and a half and it was an interesting
place because it was kind of generalist
i.t recruitment contracts and perm right
so it's good in the sense of i recruited
literally anything like the market was
uk it contracted
so super wide and obviously quite a lot
to get your head around but during my
time there like speaking to developers
project managers testers devops people
just started to kind of get a bit of a
picture of how stuff fitted together
like the software development life cycle
and probably didn't have like a market
specialism but just started to kind of
understand it quite generally i was
there for a year and a half knew that i
wanted to be in a business that was
maybe a bit bigger that maybe i had more
kind of like training yeah and at that
point i moved from living at home to
bristol oh wow why bristol so i looked
at bristol and london um always had
aspirations to go to london at some
point yeah i thought bristol was like a
good like segway to the starting point
yeah absolutely oh so you have like
mates and stuff in bristol or not uh
some friends all right some friends yeah
and like from
where i was living like kind of devices
like the obvious place if you would like
to go out and stuff so i went to bristol
and i really liked the city but yeah i
went to opus uh did like a kind of
change and transformation desk there
yeah was there for like a small period
of time like enjoy my time there but
ended up leaving that business to join
panoramic associates to essentially help
them with their like insurance uh
transformation and change desk into the
lloyd's market yeah yeah i still
regretting that in the insurance market
yeah yeah an interesting space and was
there for i think about three years and
was that contract and perm that was uh
strictly contracts just contracted yeah
so that was kind of placing like
business analysts project managers
program managers all that stuff and i
guess some good learners from that
because i've spent a lot of time like
traveling up to london doing lots of
face-to-face meetings yeah yeah because
obviously in the lord's market like a
lot of yeah it's quite traditional oh
yeah it definitely is
still walking around with like huge
folders yeah stuff like that yeah
absolutely
but it's good again please see if you're
spending lots of time with your
candidates and you're kind of really
starting to like kind of learn the space
and i guess obviously they're are they
correct me if i'm wrong but obviously
that brand they're quite well
established aren't they like they're
quite a big brand in terms of the amount
of people and like how established they
are yeah absolutely i think now probably
like around 150 people oh wow okay and
they've got like different divisions you
do like high tea insurance
like public sector and stuff but yeah
enjoy my time there i learned some
really good stuff but what i found in
that role is
the london insurance market is so
incestuous and the london agencies were
so on it yeah i thought
i thought being in bristol going into
london we're kind of on the back foot a
little bit yeah so i was actually
looking to to maybe set up an office for
them and to move to london but it's
quite random how sr2 came about because
i wrote my kind of business plan set the
london office knew alicia through a
friend and friend who set up sr2 yeah
called i'd say can i just get some two
cents on my business plan i've got
presented to my directors and you've
obviously recently set up business and
that kind of sparked a conversation
yeah i know i kind of met chris through
that and ended up taking a bit of a
segue and obviously joining sr2 to start
their contract division yeah yeah so
let's talk about that and so what did
obviously i've had chris anderson on the
show actually so like yeah what did sr 2
look like when you joined
yeah absolutely how many people was
there and uh how long they've been going
for yeah so i think i was so i joined
from memory i think like april 2019 okay
and i think it was like just under 10
people oh wow yeah and they had like no
chris and alicia had they previously
done contracts they managed people pull
with contract before or like you're
literally gonna start their contract
division from scratch pretty much yeah
absolutely so the business was very much
predominantly perm at that point oh wow
and all of their backgrounds were perm
yeah um
we had done some contract business but
it was more a case of like we've done a
really good job with some clients yeah
they've given us contract work and we'd
feel that as opposed to actually
actually going out and winning stuff
yeah yeah so the first thing that i'd
love to just
i guess just talk to you a bit about
um
was
like i think the difference if you're a
contract recruiter is like if you leave
you're just walking away from a lot more
aren't you you've built you've
absolutely worked your nuts off to build
your weekly gp yeah build that contract
book so then when you leave
you're walking away from guaranteed
money that you know you had so i guess
yeah
let's just talk a bit about that because
like what what was your experience with
that like there was no guarantee that
the sr2 journey was going to go well
yeah how do you how did you process that
because there'll be people listening
that i don't know they may think you
know what i do feel like i could grow
more or the environment i'm in now i'm
not sure i want to be in the next five
years but i'm really worried about
walking away
from this book that i built like how did
you go about dealing with that do you
think yeah it's a really good question
and to be honest i like it it was hard
was that yeah it was hard like a really
big decision um but i think i i very
much saw
it as like a career move over like a
long period of time yeah i very much
went into it open eyes knowing that
maybe my impact is going to be earning
like sorry earnings we've impacted like
year one and year two yeah but
year three year four it's like um so
hopefully if it goes well then it should
pay off yeah absolutely and there was
actually a point like i think like six
months into situ i might have called my
dad and i was like
i've made the wrong decision potentially
really i'm really struggling to get my
contract book up like mine is last year
with this and now they're this and he's
like you just gotta stick at it don't
mean it's quite natural like how do you
deal with like money-wise because i'm
sure you had like marius the contract
recruiter doing well lifestyle
and then sr2 i'm on a startup like oh
[ __ ] i can't go i can't be uh buying the
balls with the boys when i'm out like
what how did you do that probably not
very well
probably continued the lifestyle really
tried to maintain the lifestyle yeah
probably got quite a lot of debt racked
up and then obviously had to like try
and pay that all off but it's almost
like a bit of positive pressure you know
like um put myself in that situation
where i had to earn money and i kind of
had to obviously rise to the challenge
yeah yeah
when
when do you think
was the moment where you're like i made
the no i'm glad i made this decision do
you think because i think that'd be good
for people to understand because we'll
go into the challenges yeah but like
just as we're on this was it like 10
months into like no dad actually no i'm
pleased i don't know how long did it
take do you think yeah i'd probably say
like 10 months to a year really yeah
genuinely because i think um
like i said it was predominantly per
business setting up the contract
division from scratch
was like challenging obviously hiring
people and creating that culture and
it's not something that you can just do
overnight yeah um but obviously it has
absolutely paid off and it was 100 the
right decision but i probably said like
10 months to a year maybe yeah i think
that's good for people to hear isn't it
like yeah also i'm sure there's certain
things that you want to look out for in
that period ago
not sure it's going to play out but i
think
to give it a real fair crack to go you
know what i've given it a year yeah and
it's not where it should be or i'm no
i'm actually haven't got that feeling of
now this could be
big or i'm excited by it it's probably a
good time frame yeah absolutely because
i think i've interviewed quite a lot of
people
and
they're obviously doing well where they
are now but i guess they could
potentially see the potential joining
sr2 and the growth and like markets like
they're like yes it could be more
exciting i could probably do better here
it's probably a better career choice
but maybe that they're quite hung up on
what's my basic going to be like
tomorrow
what am i going to earn like month one
two three four and it's like almost
taking yourself like think about year
three yeah you've got to think a bit a
bit more longer term bit more of like a
career choice yeah yeah um okay so let's
talk about let's unpack this this sort
of this journey then so
like so just just to sort of so people
understand the context so obviously
as a predominantly pan business yeah you
went in there to build out their
contract book so in terms of the the
market i'm assuming it was tech right
and then you've ended up doing a lot in
the public sector is that right yeah is
that how the is that what you ended up
doing
yeah yeah so it's quite um
yeah i guess like an unconventional like
welcome
where i ended up going so business
predominantly
probably like private sector tech and
initially i was very much focused on
like what clients were si2 working with
who knows who's the decision makers
within those clients and institutions
what contract roles they have yeah
exactly like yeah the low hanging fruit
and i guess had like some success with
that but
i think i found the markets that they're
opening from like a contract perspective
were really saturated and there's lots
and lots of agencies that are doing kind
of like just standard like tech
recruitment yeah so it's just like i i
didn't have like huge huge success um
but there was a few clients that we were
dealing with within the public sector
that i
kind of built relationships with and and
started to do contract recruitment for
them and and built a really good
relationship and i guess during that
process started to kind of uncover like
who are these companies competitors who
else has grown in this market like
what's the drivers within this space
like and
i kind of mapped that out
and and then started to actually
predominantly build the contract book
within this space yeah it's quite
different to what srt had done
traditionally which is the private
sector okay um and since then we've kind
of built out the the public sector
division significantly and then now
we're almost retrospectively kind of
building out the private sector contract
division alongside it yeah okay nice
yeah all right cool so let's let's talk
about this for a sec so so obviously you
said it probably took around 10 months
to a year to build traction
at what point did you sort of really
start to go actually there could be some
really good growth opportunity here in
in the public sector like it seemed like
you sort of fell into that a bit
organically and then you recognized the
opportunity so as you said as we started
this commercial
astuteness or commercial awareness is
big so like talk to us a bit about
the signs of what you started to pick up
on a notice on where you then you
started going hang on a minute like this
could be a whole yeah sort of um market
in itself or what i need to double down
on like what were the signs
yeah absolutely so i think like
typical like triggers it's a good market
like candidate short
like high growth
maybe it's like not actually that
saturated in terms of other recruiters
doing it yeah
and i guess speaking to candidates they
had lots going lots going on
and there's lots of companies that were
like growing really quickly and the
companies that are growing at that time
were like quite small okay so it wasn't
like trying to break into like huge psl
yeah it might be a company that's like
five ten fifteen twenty people that got
really ambitious growth plans so
like i kind of mapped out like who are
all the players in this space
who are all the decision makers within
the space
and then when you say map out like just
so we get granted here because everyone
says map out your market yeah yeah like
like when when you say because i'm sure
you help the guys and girls of it now so
like yeah that process is it as simple
as going on linkedin looking at the
people finding out who like is that
literally what you did and then you just
like just really tried to gather all
that knowledge yeah and then sort of
work away is that is that how you did
that
um like kind of but a lot of the really
really really exciting businesses are
like the not obvious ones okay
interesting so like then that if you
look to them on linkedin they might be
like literally a handful of people so
you might not think they're that excited
so i think it's just the kind of general
really good contract recruitment like
when you speak to a candidate you're
doing like cv stripping yeah um you're
asking them like obviously what else
they got going on who are they speaking
to
um and just being like really granular
trying to use your candidates to get as
much like kind of market information as
possible and then maybe when you're
speaking to your clients asking them
like who's your competitors within the
space
and within the consultancy world uh
consultancies will partner with other
consultancies on bids right so it might
be that we're doing loads of recruitment
for one consultancy in the database but
they might out outsource all their tech
development stuff to another consultancy
right okay so building relationships
with the kind of like direct disease
consultancies they can say actually this
company is doing similar stuff to
actually go and speak to them yeah yeah
and basically just like systematically
did that again and again and again again
and there's probably got like a list of
like 50 yeah and then we've just kind of
worked through that list
yeah okay cool so
correct if i'm wrong here but like i
feel like if you're a good contract
recruiter you're good at all those
things that you just said but
i could do all of that get the list but
and then i could be just really terrible
at like actually getting business from
these people
so let's just talk a bit about
like what what's been like the most
consistent and effective way of marriage
to get into these 50 accounts that
you've gone you know what these may not
be the most exciting business right now
but they they bloody well could be yeah
like what i know you said building
relationships in these things but like
what has ended up being yeah that
consistent and effective way of getting
into these accounts do you think that's
really worked for you yeah absolutely um
so i think for me it's like i guess like
being like kind of market specialist
like really understanding like the
drivers in the market
i'd say like just really good email
approaches have been like genuinely
quite quite
quite decent like i understand you've
won this project i understand you might
need to hire all these roles i
understand the project's doing xyz we've
just delivered this project for your
competitor here's a testimonial and
here's actually like an example team
that have delivered this type of
projects in the past
that have got all of the relevant skills
and if you're sending that to like a
managing director or director of
consultancy and you're name dropping a
competitor and yeah you've got some
credibility
and then you're calling them up and
saying i've just sent this email and
you're talking through that like
immediately you're kind of having a
conversation at this level yeah rather
than just like male shotting a random
developer yeah yeah like one's you're
not talking ones and twos you're talking
about marius how can you support us
deliver this project or how can you
provide the talent that we need over the
six twelve months yeah absolutely so i
think that's one aspect of it um but i
think as a team we've really tried to um
think about how we can like consistently
add value to our clients so i think a
lot of i guess recruiters will be quite
transactional in the sense that we'll
get a job place a job get a job place
job which is great but that's almost
like kind of like level one for us we're
we're we're thinking like we run these
tech leadership meetups so a lot of our
best clients we've actually when did you
start those
um i'd say like
probably like
like nine ten months in okay nice so we
run um like leaders in tech is like a
more private set to one the leaders in
government is our more public sector
folks one we run these industry panel
events and
we speak to our candidates and clients
and say like
what what hot topics at the moment yeah
and then we might talk about what's top
of mind yeah absolutely they might say
like um managing teams remotely yeah and
and kind of like delivering a project
successfully so it's highly relevant to
the clients so we'll speak to our
clients and say do you want to appear on
this podcast some of your competitors
appear on there so it's kind of free pr
for them it's great for like the actual
managers like personal brands and they
can obviously get like a bit of an
insight to maybe what some of their
competitors are doing yeah so it's like
actually adding value and then we do
other things where we might have placed
20 30 contractors with this company
and then we're saying how do you
actually like manage your contractors
from like a performance perspective and
they'll be like well we kind of check in
and we'll be like well as an agency we
can check in with the contracts every
month
put that feedback in like a really like
eligible format maybe like a spreadsheet
and then provide it back to them yeah so
we're trying to like help with like
performance management and there's loads
of like things we've done as a business
to like
try and add value to our clients above
and beyond just
like defending jobs yeah yeah nice and i
think having that kind of um
that focus has allowed us to become like
the exclusive suppliers with a lot of
these companies and still plays ones and
twos we might be on 120 deals with one
yeah we need to deal with something like
because we're like a kind of real
partner for them yeah yeah i love that
yeah so what what what was your i don't
know like how it's working now have you
been the leader and all these things but
like what like at the height of like
where you were just concerned about your
own billings most of the time yeah what
was the height of your book and then we
can just revert i know people would want
to go just want me to ask you things
like okay well when you've got up to
like 15k weekly gp what you're doing
differently in these things but like
what was it at the height just for
context for people uh yeah i think they
were like 16 16 and a half yeah yeah
okay so few things i know what people
would love me to ask is one what the
hell did your day plan look like to that
stage and how did you structure that
because i'm sure there's a lot going on
yeah and i guess let me just start
firstly with like as you went on that
journey what would you say you're
speaking a lot around like that mindset
of adding value getting into clients
like what would you say were the main
differences like you were doing maybe
day to day or the things that you really
doubled down on um when you was sort of
getting to that point of sixteen and six
and a half compared to
six seven eight weeks yeah you know what
i mean i don't know if there's any key
things in there but i know people want
me to ask that yeah absolutely i think
um when we started off we're probably
like doing the standard like fake it to
make it okay so we're probably
approaching these clients and saying
we're the specialists yeah we deliver
all these projects we work with all
these companies and like trying to like
create this kind of side that we're like
the absolute go-to company yeah and then
fast forward like 12 months we actually
became that company we actually worked
for all the top clients we actually
delivered all the big projects we
actually had all these testimonials
right and i guess at that kind of um at
that point that's where we really
started to see success because the
emails and the approaches that we were
sending
they actually were genuine yeah there
was a whole team ready and we did have
like um some some solid testimonials
from their competitors so it's actually
having like a really good response right
yeah yeah so just just build so
basically you just watch your absolute
socks off to build credibility and then
you actually
you yeah you you earn that credibility
yeah absolutely and i think the more
work that you do within a space you can
obviously start to build like a really
strong personal brand and yeah obviously
talking about kind of like me quite a
lot but but absolutely the the team that
we that we built like myself and jack
and chris and everyone we essentially
aligned several vertical specialism
within these clients that we recruited
in right and then they all became like
like kind of becoming the go-to people
within those markets so they're trying
to build their personal brand and
they're doing meetups and they're trying
to do like linkedin stuff so if
everyone's doing that and we're all
trying to win similar clients we've just
got like so much noise so what i'll take
from that and for people listening is
like you always hear it but like you
have to take your reputation seriously
yeah so when so like as you were sort of
hopefully getting to the point like you
said where you had great testimonials
you've got the credibility work with
some of the best clients
like if you
tried to cut corners or you didn't do
the right thing or whatever leading up
to that you wouldn't have then got all
that traction
so like even though when you maybe think
like you're not getting anywhere or
whatever you still have to it seems like
really stick to your reputation and
think about the long game yeah
absolutely and i think it's all good and
well like working with consultancies and
and
and having success in this space but
fundamentally if you're like an
exclusive
uh supplier to these these companies and
you don't deliver the team
they're obviously liable for all these
costs so it's great but it's like
with great power comes great
responsibility kind of thing so you
can't not fill the roles so there's
loads of times where you absolutely got
put like in loads of hours you've got to
put in the grafts if you have dropouts
you absolutely have to like replace them
with decent people and as a team like
you've got actually really take it
seriously but you can't just send this
send a cv if someone is like all right
but probably has probably is going to
drop out because it's going to impact
their project massively so i think just
sending really quality people and um
just taking it seriously to be fair
enough yeah yeah and and clients will
absolutely notice that yeah like there
was a case recently where
andy one of our guys was working on a
really senior role was interviewing all
the candidates via teams before he put
them forward to the client had this
great candidate on paper put them
forward hadn't seen to be booked in and
then he did the interview on teams and
then just thought nah he's just not
going to be right called the client was
i'm pulling him out
did another interview the guy came
across really well was really genuine
said right we'll put him in and he got
the job and the client was like i
respect that so yeah yeah yeah exactly
you're not just trying to like slam
anyone else yeah likes to have someone
into our team yeah yeah hey everyone a
real quick one from me this podcast
would not be possible without our
amazing podcast partners vincerie and
sauce breaker because you listen to this
podcast you're able to get your hands on
exclusive savings on both of these
award-winning products if you're all a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincerie who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
sourcebreaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products so
let's unpack really quickly then before
we get into the leadership there's some
pac day plan then yeah so like just how
did you go how the hell did you go about
like
just managing your day at the height of
things maybe compared to
when you were just like maybe a bit more
all over the place and like i don't know
like how yeah what did your day plan
look like
on that when you're like 16 and six and
a half yeah a week it's a really good
question i'd love to have a really good
answer to this did you just give us what
yeah just what um what it look what a
typical day would look like yeah
absolutely i i guess at that point is
probably very resourcing heavy okay
because we because we kind of had like
we got to a point where we'd won the
clients that needed some win yeah yeah
so it's very much just a hundred miles
an hour trying to kind of like fill the
job so i guess probably quite quite
resourcing heavy there was a lot of uh
kind of meetings with clients discussing
like right like this demand or like this
project coming out i guess at my peak of
billing was the was the time i had like
the biggest team from management
perspective okay so
2021 was when i had my kind of best book
but that's when we kind of grew the team
and i was managing the most people so a
lot of i guess was like checking in with
the team making sure that everyone had
how did you manage that with all that
because that's what a lot of people
struggle with yeah did you set
boundaries with the team did you like
like how did you go about making sure
like all your time didn't get obviously
it should hopefully benefit you and
everyone else involved yeah long term
but
obviously if you're you're responsible
for that and like you said you clearly
take your reputation seriously how did
you manage that whilst also growing and
managing the team time-wise yeah um i
think we've been
i want to say like lucky but i guess
we've done it like time and time again
but
whenever we interview people we try and
get people on like the upward trajectory
of their careers yeah yeah and it's
quite hard to like know who is like an
sr2 person quite i just kind of like
define it but i think we've done a
really good job of hiring people most of
them have been experienced yeah but that
are like motivated that wants to do well
and they're like kind of good humans
they've got kind of like good values and
stuff so i think hiring people have got
experience putting them into this
environment kind of showing them what's
possible showing them standard like
getting them to become like an industry
specialist and then i guess like kind of
delegating responsibility to people and
empowering them and obviously
if you're getting them on that upward
trajectory they probably value autonomy
quite a lot don't they yeah absolutely
and they're super motivated they want to
do well um jack worked really close with
me as and kind of helped me to manage
that team but i think we just kept like
delegating and empowering people and
kind of giving them responsibility so
it's not about me at all it's about
everyone else and everyone else is kind
of like manage their own stuff and also
check in and kind of help and sitting on
calls and meetings and stuff but you
kind of want to get to a point whereby
you almost don't need to be there and
the team's like actually kind of
managing itself and if someone's having
a tricky call someone's going to jump in
and be like actually this how we do
things or this we should do this
and obviously that takes time but i
think it's quite fortunate like
the team is
i guess like so strong and like so
cohesive that
it doesn't need as much managing as you
think yeah i think obviously um in
london obviously it's kind of a newer
time and it's a bit fresher and
obviously highlight trainees and
graduates like that's a that's like
different story yeah and it would take
time to get to a point where we had it
in bristol yeah yeah but um yeah so i
want to go into the leadership piece but
i have to ask i think i said to you
before we start i didn't like that i
think what what i'm taking from our chat
so far has you just been relentless
yeah like you've got high standards
you're like that you've really committed
to making it work yeah and it's
obviously paid off but tell us obviously
as i said i spoke to a couple of your
colleagues um i was like what would you
love me to ask uh marissa yeah obviously
alicia highlighted this story where you
pretended to have a ticket for like a
conference or something and you drove up
to wales just to
try and get in front of someone like
tell us a bit about this story because i
think there might be something people
could take from this or yeah so i guess
that was probably like the initial
stages whereby like we saw an
opportunity in the market we knew um the
clients we wanted to work with we didn't
have that credibility yeah so i guess it
is that kind of like fake it to make it
so there's one company in particular
hiring loads of contractors and i knew
the guy who was doing it and like
literally tried everything like
reference called yeah
really good email like just like cold
calling him loads like approaching by
linkedin everything like commenting on
his linkedin status and saying oh great
really interesting just nothing worked
and then he posted said i'm speaking at
uh swansea con okay and then i messaged
him saying oh great i'm gonna be there i
can't wait to hear your talk about like
humanities and stuff and then he
actually came back and he was like oh
like just random you're there it's like
really techy conference but great like
well i'm happy to meet for a coffee and
then afterwards i was like i've actually
now got to get a ticket
so it went online the tickets were sold
out oh wow and i contacted the ticket
organizer and he was like yeah we're
absolutely sold out
so then i had to um drive to swansea we
didn't have to have to but
yeah yeah so in my head i was like
obviously i'm right now there you go
yeah yeah there's an opportunity to meet
this guy face to face and obviously he
thinks i've got a ticket so um
i drove to swansea
and then waited in the lobby and meshed
him saying oh like um i've just
literally stepped out from the front
just having five minutes and he was like
i'll come um i'll come on and meet
outside and then had this meeting with
him um and obviously
yeah it's just kind of like it went
fairly well but essentially he was like
don't we don't have any like immediate
needs um and i think like a kind of good
question i asked was like yeah fine but
we're doing loads of work in this space
if there's ever a candidate if i see i
should call you about
who are they yeah and then he was like
um if you ever see this person right
then then give me a call you found out
you found out what
he values or the type of skill set and
people that yeah okay what his needs and
then went back found that person and
then called him up and i've got the
person he was like oh great let's let's
have a chat there we go that kind of
built into a relationship i love that
that's a great story yeah
awesome mate so let's talk about this
journey you've been on so let's talk a
bit about
i guess leadership team culture these
things so i guess
as you've like you said you started to
build out the team in bristol and then
when did you obviously move to london it
was only recently wasn't that yeah
literally december last year december
last year cool and obviously now is it
you and jack isn't it that are really
responsible for growing the sr2 london
footprint yeah
and i guess thinking there is you had a
lot of london-based clients i'm assuming
and yeah i guess it like you said you'd
always like the idea of getting to
london
but now you can just be in the mix of it
and you can go out and see people really
easily and just be really on the ground
yeah yeah so i guess how are you
thinking about culture then so i guess
first question maybe to uncover some of
this and how you think about it like
what what would you say like the i don't
know the the free non-negotiables or
three key pillars you think that
make up or contribute to a
high-performing culture within a
recruitment team do you think
yeah that's a good question um i think i
think having a team of like like-minded
people
and like i said trying to get people on
the upward trajectory is is is really
critical um
because i think when everyone's on the
same page everyone wants to do well
everyone's really supportive everyone's
really bought into the vision and the
why
that's it kind of allows you to achieve
amazing things but i think if we'd have
had two or three people on the team that
were turning up late weren't really
first didn't take the job seriously that
would just dilute the whole thing okay
so i think it's hard to obviously get
that but trying to have a group of
like-minded people who are really
passionate and like motivated is is is
one thing so that's standard so really
really stay true to your standards and
make sure they're maintained and no one
as you said dilute in them or bring
those standards down yeah absolutely and
then i think i guess like secondly is
just trying to be
really clear on like what those
standards are okay um communicating them
yeah like kind of what are the
expectations and stuff and um rateeb our
um
client success manager did a really good
session recently where it was like um
temperature checking our culture
and then kind of working out what our
like non-negotiables are team and he was
basing it all around like the all blacks
and like they're like 12 things that
they have i love that so he did this
whole session and and as a teamwork is
this one of your colleagues yeah like
what do we stand for as a team yeah
and we actually like kind of
written all out and then we can kind of
like refer back to that it's almost like
kind of having like like a bit of like
like running it's like a bit like a
sports team yeah for sure well all
agreeing that this is what we live by
and this is what we what our standards
are like you said there's no
now everyone knows so like if they're
not
up to that then why not and let's talk
about it or if they keep showing that
they're not that then maybe they're
people that
we need to protect those standards right
and the culture yeah okay absolutely um
and then just trying to think what the
third thing would be again what's what's
been quite good about the um the kind of
contract team is because we've had
these clients that are kind of um giving
us roles when people join we can give
them like quite a warm landing and
actually like kind of help them and and
and kind of give them like a little bit
of like success initially by by filling
some jobs and
the team again is brought into
everyone's individual success as well
right so if someone's doing well
everyone's happy it's not like a culture
whereby like it's like oh i don't want
him to do work because it's like really
competitive yeah so i think again just
like supporting
your team
one wanting them to do well helping them
to do well and then kind of getting
everyone in in in like a similar mindset
yeah nice so i think i remember asking
chris this but it'd be good to get your
take on it i think if i
like
from most of the recruitment company
owning conversations i've had they would
typically say i'd rather i would prefer
to like grow our own talent
rather than sort of take home people
that have got experience with criminal
experience and typically just really
high level they're sort of assumption is
i can hire marriage he's got three years
experience but he could come with a lot
of bad habits and
um we don't want that or like we could
really try and instill what we want him
to do but he just can't shake it off
blah blah so like what why do you think
you've been like you said you you've you
you guys have done a really good job of
hiring people upward trajectory yeah
which means typically people are
experienced how have you done that well
do you think like how how have you not
had people that just have bad habits and
they can't shake them off and
damage your culture rather than add to
it like how have you done well
hiring experienced people do you think
yeah it's a really good question um
i think in our interview process there's
like three stages usually so myself and
jack did the initial one
and i think like trying to hire like
good humans
so people obviously that's one of our
important non-negotiable values i think
just hiring people that got good values
people that are decent people
um and i guess people that will kind of
like uphold like what we kind of stand
for and i think
like throughout the interview approach
me and jackson in this one and then two
of the team members will do the next one
okay and we actually really value like
their input yeah so it might be that me
and jack are like we kind of like them
might get them to meet the team and they
might give us some really good feedback
and say look i don't think they're right
for those reasons we actually really
value that and then finally like chris
would do the final stage and
again it's hard to say like what we've
kind of looked for and how we've managed
to do it but
uh one of our other values just like
don't be a [ __ ] and again it's just
trying to hide like decent people that
are on the upwards trajectory and then
when they come in trying to like i guess
show them what standards we've set and
then i guess give them like look
ex is joined he's 12 months in he's be
all of his career best he's now running
12 grand a week this is what he did to
get there
you've obviously done quite well in your
own business but we want to kind of take
you on this journey and then i guess
just trying to like take people on that
journey okay failure so again because
that's standard doesn't it and really
making sure you protect
the values and but what surely it hasn't
always been clean sailing yeah sorry so
like yeah
where like how have you ever have you
have you ever or have you gone about
like nipping in the bud like people just
like yeah i just said going like hanging
a minute now like that isn't how we do
things or we're not gonna stand for that
yeah so i think there's been like a
small small handful of people that we've
hired and quite quickly
it's been obvious that it's it's kind of
like not a good match so let's just talk
about that not specific people but like
what makes it obvious is it you're just
hearing them talk on the phone like nah
that's that's not is it is it their
their i don't know like is it their mind
i don't know like have you tried to help
them and they just really haven't
listened like what what made it obvious
yeah i think there's a few things just
general like
just like real negativity maybe okay
yeah i think i think just like people
that are just generally quite negative
like glass always half empty yeah um i
think maybe people that
are not willing to kind of like change
and not willing to like kind of accept
like help and training maybe
yeah exactly like obviously we
absolutely value like what experience
people have in the past and we want
people to come in like share their ideas
and stuff but maybe if they have like a
certain bad habit and we're like we do
things this way this is why i'm having
some really good success and they're
like yeah no but i've always done it
this way yeah so i guess yeah okay those
types of people yeah it's quite obvious
quite quickly that is that if there's a
bit of a clash
but i think you have got a fail fast and
it's most uncomfortable in this thing in
the world obviously getting rid of
people however
um the longer that you do keep hold of
people
it's not good for them it's not going to
be right now and then equally it might
kind of dilute what you've got as well
yeah yeah so so it's hard and i think
sometimes you might not always make the
right decision by getting rid of someone
but
i think you do have a bit bit of a gut
feel most of the time your brain is
probably right yeah absolutely so as as
we come to an end then like let's talk a
bit more about the future and what's on
the horizon then so obviously london and
december yeah obviously obviously i went
to the office obviously initially it was
like an office of like what five or six
seven people and then you've got the
bigger space yeah so
i guess firstly just just curious what
what um
what's been like difficult so far that
maybe you least expected yeah let's just
start there what's what's what's maybe
been the challenge at least expected so
far yeah absolutely
i'd say like managing the team that i
have done in bristol is obviously a very
experienced team and obviously coming
into london you're obviously hiring like
a new group of people yeah and you're
obviously again trying to kind of like
recreate what you've created before yeah
so they're trying to reverse engineer
and work out like how do we actually do
what we did what contributes to that and
then obviously trying to like implement
that um
i think from like a general like
bringing like grads in and train them
that's it's not new because we have done
academies in bristol but it's not
something that i'm like absolutely the
best person really polish that because
again i guess my kind of background's
been more kind of bringing in
experienced people so that's been i
guess like it's a challenge but it's a
really good challenge yeah and a good
learning experience absolutely yeah and
we've got people on like a 12-week
like training program yeah so it's it's
like a positive challenge not kind of
excited to learn it's definitely been
different
and then what what's been um
what's been like a real positive so
finding highlights so far yeah i think
um i guess just from like a higher
perspective like when we're there now um
so we've got i think the 13 now yeah
nice and then we've got that's a good
critical mason right there yeah
absolutely and we've got like multiple
people in the process across like
different uh roles but when we were
looking at london when we moved to
london like the consensus was like the
market's really good we're harder anyone
who's decent building good numbers it's
really hard to hire people who've got
experience you have to do pure grads and
then we came
and we've actually managed to hire loads
of really good experienced people and i
don't know what's yeah like is that you
think i i think it's fair to say that i
don't know most people outside looking
in i think you guys done a really good
job of building brands yeah um
do you think that that's really helped
you guys cut through the noise and
you're living by i guess now because i
feel like if i'm an experienced
recruiter and i look at your business
but there's you and i sit in front of
you like there's so many
people you can now point at to go yep he
was where you was this is now where he
is was where you are do you know what i
mean i feel like you've really got that
track record now yeah that probably
massively helps and i'm assuming you
really make sure you communicate say hey
look i know it will be i know you're
walking away from a lot or it's going to
be scary but
this is what it could look like if
you're prepared to put in what we're
going to put in yeah absolutely and i
think also like i haven't like talked
about this that much but
sr2 is a business like doing the the
people over profit mentality
five percent of profits to like
underrepresent charities do like the
volunteering do load stuff around like
diversity and tech
uh do loads of stuff like helping other
reps into groups against coding
do lots of stuff with charities helping
them partner with individuals to do like
tech support yes there's so much stuff
and i think um speaking to people
nowadays like yes people want to earn
money yes people have a career but i
think people are becoming a bit more
conscious of that yeah and especially as
like b corps started to get kind of more
recognized like there was a bit of a
shift so
you actually
got certified didn't you yeah
absolutely i think if you've actually
got purpose as a business and why and
it's not just to make loads of cash yeah
then i think you'll attract people
because they might be doing well at
another company but they might actually
be really passionate about giving back
and diversity so giving them opportunity
to do well earning good money but
actually be part of something bigger and
get involved with that stuff i think
it's been really good yeah whilst also
doing a really good thing yeah
absolutely the amazing thing about it
yeah so um what are you excited about
and let's let's finish there like what
are you excited about then the future
for you and the london team yeah
absolutely so obviously we're 30 now um
the office capacity is 22. yeah so you
want to be kind of hitting that probably
by like maybe like q3 q4 yeah um and
then going again
next year potentially like doubling but
i think just like continuing to
build the the culture in london continue
to kind of actually like build the
business as a whole
um excited to like get the meetups
active again like actually in person
yeah be good because we're running them
virtually at the moment but we had some
some some really good fun actually
running like physical events in london i
think definitely people were up for
doing that again i'd say yeah absolutely
um and i think i think it's just like
from like a personal perspective like
going on a journey around like
getting more experience to the training
development from like a graduate
perspective yeah because that's
definitely new
and london life yeah exactly yeah yeah
yeah well look maris i think clearly
you've um
taken the opportunity you had with both
hands yeah so kudos to you mate and
really excited to to see where the
london team is in another year two years
three years
thank you very much cheers
thank you so much for listening to the
episode i hope you enjoyed it and got
value from the conversation if you did
enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode
[Music]